(cris des manifestants)
- Des citoyens en colère après
le drame ont pris d'assaut
les rues du 10e arrondissement.
(cris des manifestants)
Du gaz lacrymogène a été
tiré par les policiers,
les manifestants ont répliqué
avec des projectiles.
Plus tôt, un homme de 69 ans,
de nationalité française, aurait
fait feu à trois endroits : dans
un ce e e communautaire kurde,
un restaurant et
un salon de coiffure.
ALI DALEK, témoin
- On connaît des gens
qui travaillent au salon
de coiffure. On est rentrés
dans le salon de coiffure,
on a vu, puis on a...
Les gens, ils ont interpellé
un mec, un monsieur assez âgé,
un peu âgé, grand, tout,
et il y a trois blessé
dans le salon.
- Des éléments préliminaires
laissent croire que
la communauté kurde pourrait
avoir été la cible.
L'an dernier, l'homme avait
été arrêté pour tentative
d'homicide, après avoir attaqué
un camp de migrants avec un
sabre. Il venait d'être libéré.
Dans un gazouillit, le président
de la république française
déclare que...
La procureur rappelle que
l'enquête ne fait que commencer.
LAURE BECCUAU, procureure,
Tribunal judiciaire de Paris
- Quant aux motifs racistes
des faits, eh bien, ces motifs
vont évidemment faire partie
des investigations qui viennent
de débuter, encore une fois,
avec un très grand déploiement
d'effectifs.
- Le ministre de l'Intérieur
a annoncé une présence policière
accrue.
GÉRALD DARMANIN, ministre
Intérieur et Outre-mer, France
- J'ai demandé à tous
les services de police
et de gendarmerie, à Paris,
bien sûr, et ailleurs sur
le territoire national,
de protéger particulièrement
avec des gardes statiques
24 heures sur 24, des policiers,
des gendarmes, les lieux où
se réunit la communauté kurde.
(slogan)
- Les violences surviennent
dans un contexte de tension
pour la communauté kurde.
Il y a 10 ans, trois militantes
ont été tuées dans le même
quartier. En trame de fond,
il y a également le conflit
kurde qui perdure en Turquie.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.